la CNIL et compétente vis-à-vis de Tik
Tok pour deux textes deux ensembles de
réglementation le rgpd donc un ensemble
important avec de très nombreuses règles
sur les données personnelles et leurs
traitement et un texte beaucoup plus
spécifique la directive iprivée-ci pour
ce qui est de la règle de protection des
terminaux c'est-à-dire du fait qu'on ne
peut lire ou écrire dans votre terminal
avec l'application TikTok qu'avec votre
consentement sauf si c'est nécessaire au
fonctionnement du service que vous avez
demandé la CNIL n'est donc c'est déjà
assez large et la CNIL n'est pas
compétente pour tout un tas de de
législation plus spécifique sur le
caractère approprié ou non des contenus
haineux des informations etc etc même si
évidemment c'est toujours en lien avec
la licéité du traitement de façon
générale mais avec ce type de traitement
la CNIL serait compétentable de
raisonnement la clinique très compétente
pour tout donc voilà c'est pour signaler
que nous arrêtons au traitement de la de
la
alors nous étions compétents nous étions
compétents pour TikTok sur ces deux
séries de disposition et des contrôles
ont été lancés début 2020 à la fois sur
l'application le site par questionnaire
par voie écrite etc le rgpd prévoit le
règlement général sur la protection des
données prévoient un système de guichet
unique ce guichet unique fait que des
entreprises des groupes qui ont une
activité à l'échelle de l'Union
européenne n'ont qu'une seule CNIL
qu'une seule autorité de protection des
données comme intermédiaires
généralement au lieu de leur siège le
règlement parle d'établissement
principal en juillet 2020 mi-2020 à peu
près Tik Tok a créé un établissement
principal un système d'établissement
principal en Irlande en réorganisant la
manière dont étaient régies ces
traitements je laisserai madame Kieffer
éventuellement compléter sur ce point
après le propos liminaire et c'est
maintenant Tik Tok Irlande
qui sont
correspondables d'un grand nombre des
traitements de Tik Tok et ces Tik Tok
Irlande et donc l'autorité irlandaise
qui est compétente à partir du moment où
nous a été opposé d'une certaine façon
cette structure qui est TikTok tout à
fait légitime à faire nous sommes
retrouvés incompétents sur les
procédures que nous avions lancées à
l'exception de ce qui pourrait toucher
la directive eprivée ici parce que pour
une raison un peu compliquée
d'articulation des textes pour cette
règle spécifique là chaque pays demeure
compétent pour les utilisateurs les
terminaux sur son territoire donc à
partir de ce moment-là nous avons
transféré les plaintes que nous avions
les contrôles les constats les
investigations les interrogations rien
de tout ça n'était abouti à la difficile
et depuis lors nous sommes dans un
mécanisme de coopération avec l'autorité
irlandaise c'est une coopération je
tiens à le souligner à la demande
express assistante de la présidente de
la CNIL nous avons été en contact
régulier avec nos homologues irlandais
pour leur demander où en était les
procédures ou en était les constats
comment cela avancer
nous ne sommes pas les seuls en Europe
mais en tout cas voilà on avait fait des
constats des contrôles on leur a passé
ces éléments et on est régulièrement
revenu vers eux en leur demandant que
les procédures puissent aboutir sous une
instruction qui relève de leur
responsabilités
irlandaise et donc ça c'est c'est public
sous le contrôle encore une fois de
Karine a donc deux instructions en cours
une de ces instructions à donner lieu à
un projet ça a été annoncé qui a été
envoyé au Comité européen de la
protection des données qui concerne
notamment les questions du traitement
des données des mineurs le contenu du
projet n'est pas public en revanche il
passe maintenant dans le mécanisme de
coopération qui est prévue par le
Règlement général à la protection des
données et on peut espérer une décision
je l'espère au milieu de l'année 2023
une autre procédure est toujours en
cours et là il n'y a pas de projet de
décision qui était
envoyer donc
nous n'avons pas vu ce projet devrait je
dis bien devrait inclure la question des
transferts sur laquelle nous avions
particulièrement demandé à l'autorité
irlandaise de regarder des derniers
contacts que nous avons eu avec nos
homologues irlandais nous espérons mais
là encore pour l'instant nous n'avons
pas qu'un projet un projet soit circuler
partager au Comité européen la
protection des données vers le milieu de
l'année 2023 déclenchant ensuite le
système de coopération donc une décision
définitive et espérée vers le milieu de
l'année pour le premier dossier une un
projet de décision à adopter en
coopération de l'autre côté
je signale que le contrôle et le
fonctionnement d'une application même si
c'est les mêmes règles pour les pour les
cookies c'est en réalité techniquement
très différent des sites Web qui
expliquent en effet les choses en deux
temps